MALE SPEAKER: Welcome to what's
new in N-- not the real name.
FEMALE SPEAKER: But
we can talk about all
of the new features added
in this version of Android.
For example, Marshmallow brought
you Doze and App Standby,
and now N is bringing
new Doze again.
But it's so much more.
The goal here is to coalesce
back on activity whenever
the screen is off
and not necessarily
when the device is stationary.
So this brings Doze out of
the "tablet on a shelf" model
and into the "user out about
and needs her battery" scenario.
So shortly after the
screen is turned off,
Doze will be activated, and all
network access and background
jobs will be restricted into
maintenance windows that
happen every "N" minutes.
But in this lighter wait
mode, alarms, wake clocks,
and Wi-Fi scans will
all happen normally,
and all of the other Doze
best practices still apply.
Cloud messaging.
Of course, this is all an
extension of Doze mode.
So if the device
is stationary, then
the Marshmallow-flavored
Doze will kick in.
MALE SPEAKER: If you're
actually using your device,
there's also a ton
of cool new features,
like two apps on screen
at the same time.
That's right.
Smartphones and tablets will
support split screen windows,
where two apps are placed
right up next to one another.
Now this doesn't change the
usual activity lifecycle,
though.
There's still only one app
that's resumed at a time.
The other app will be
paused and not stopped,
so it should be able to
update you with new messages
and keep a video
playing, for instance.
There's a new resizable
activity attribute
you add to your manifest
entry to control how you work
with multiple window
mode and also attributes
for setting a minimum size.
There's also a fancy new
LAUNCH_ADJACENT intent flag
to hint that you'd like the
launched activity to be opened
alongside the current activity.
And there's a little something
extra for Android TV users--
Picture-in-Picture.
Now your app can continue
to run in miniature form
on top of everything else.
Of course, that
means you should hide
things that are
totally unreadable
in Picture-in-Picture.
There's new callbacks for
when you enter and leave
this mode if you
choose to support it,
which you should, particularly
for video apps out there.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So yeah,
multi-window wins the day.
But there are so
many new features
that have nothing
to do with the UI,
like Data Saver, which was
introduced on a per-app basis
a while back so that
the user can specify
certain apps to be Wi-Fi only
and keep their data costs down.
But with N, we added
a device-wide option.
This means your app really needs
to be good at not wasting data
and at failing gracefully if you
cannot access the network right
now.
So to help you, we
added an API call
so you can check if your
app is network restricted
and maybe try a header to
let the user know your app is
in "save data" mode.
MALE SPEAKER: One of the most
noticeable things in Android N,
particularly for
end users, is going
to be the total visual
redesign of notifications.
Yup, all the standard
templates have
changed quite significantly.
You'll also notice
some of the features
from Android Wear are
being expanded upon
and making their way onto
other Android devices.
For example, you'll
be able to use
remote input to send
replies directly
from the notification shade.
You'll also be able to
show the sent message
history in the notification,
so you'll always
know exactly where you
left the conversation.
Now grouping notifications
make it a lot easier
to handle multiple
notifications from the same app
by creating a single summary
notification now allowing users
to expand it into individual
actionable and dismissable
notifications.
Grouping is enabled
by default on all app,
but you'll want to
customize the summary
notification to make for a
great notification experience.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Speaking of
making things great for users,
encrypting your phone is
great and secure and awesome,
but it does mean
that you have to be
around to help it boot up.
So if your phone restarts
while you're sleeping,
your alarm clock
has died as well.
Direct Boot will
allow the device
to fully wake up, to have
alarms, and to receive calls.
This way, users won't
be stuck in alert,
and then they can
put in their password
when they go to
use their device.
But it also means that if
your app handles calls or SMS
messages, uses TalkBack,
or triggers an alarm,
you will now need to be crypto
aware, which means state it
in your manifest
when targeting N,
and you will need to
specify which files should
be device encrypted or
credential encrypted
so that you can receive
special treatment.
MALE SPEAKER: And speaking
of special treatment,
Marshmallow brought permissions
requests to the user in context
with run time permissions.
But for storage, taking
it a step farther,
instead of having to request
access to everything,
apps can now request access to a
specific folder, such as Alarms
or Pictures, with full support
for both internal and removable
media volumes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Also, heads up.
Some of your implicit
broadcasts are changing.
As part of our continued
focus on Project Svelte,
we want to make background
activity even more efficient.
So all apps targeting the N that
listen for connectivity action
broadcasts in their
manifest and rely
on it to launch their process
will no longer be woken,
because a single network switch
can result in a bazillion
apps all waking up
when maybe two of them
will actually do something.
And this is horrible
for performance,
and the time has come to fix
it because "perfmatters."
However, if your app
is already running,
it can still receive
this broadcast
with context registerReceiver.
But as of N plus,
you will no longer
be able to send or receive a new
picture or new video broadcast.
Instead, JobScheduler has
been extended to trigger jobs
on a constant provider update,
which is a much better way
to handle a response to
a picture being taken
and which means users won't
wonder why the camera app keeps
freezing.
Time to migrate to JobScheduler.
But if you're afraid of
JobScheduler, just tweet me.
We can chat.
Android N also allows users
to specify multiple locales
and settings, which
means apps can all
show search results
in multiple languages
or avoid offering
translations for languages
that the user already knows.
So the full list of
locales for a user
can be accessed via
Localelist_getDefault.
MALE SPEAKER: So check out
the links in the description
for everything, and
I mean everything
you need to know about
Android N-- ot the real name.
Not-- not yet.
[MUSIC PLAYING]